while he first appeared in ant-man and
the wasp one division has officially
made jimmy woo a major part of the mcu
this is his history in the comics from
his 1950s origins to his time leading
the agents of atlas
wu's first comic book appearance came in
1956's four part mini-series yellow claw
which was published by marvel when they
were known as atlas comics
in the comic wu is a chinese-american
fbi agent tasked with hunting down the
yellow claw
an ancient chinese mystic who seeks to
conquer the world
unsurprisingly this comic features many
racist depictions of asian people with
the yellow claw himself being a yellow
peril caricature
however jimmy wu is a positive exception
to the largely negative depictions of
asian characters and comics of the era
according to columnist jeff yang
the first issue features a fairly
clear-cut espionage story but yellow
claw goes to some wild places in the
next few issues
each story sees wu foil the claw's plan
before he escapes
the claw's granny suwan who we recruited
to aid him in his quest for world
domination secretly helps woo throughout
the mini-series
wu went dormant for 10 years following
his debut then he returned to marvel
comics which had successfully rebranded
itself away from its atlas days
in 1967 strange tales number 160 captain
america brings wood and nick fury at
shield headquarters because he might
have a lead on an ongoing case called
project blackout
fury then tells the duo how he and cap
investigated a mysterious force inside
the statue of liberty
this enigmatic enemy planned on turning
everyone on america's east coast into
obedient zombies
wu reveals in the following issue that
the mastermind behind this thwarted plan
is the yellow claw who was long thought
to be dead
as for wu he officially joined shield in
1968's nick fury agent of shield number
two
even helps the agency fight godzilla
when the giant lizard attacks north
america on the 24 issue godzilla series
released between 1977 and 1979.
wu appears in a six-part mini-series
from 1988 entitled nick fury vs shield
or does he the first issue begins with
an advanced idea mechanic ship filled
with hydra agents attacking fury's squad
they managed to steal a power core from
a downed helicarrier fury tracks the
core to the roxon industrial research
complex in new jersey through a sleeper
agent named jack rowlands
fury reports his findings to the shield
executive board and they respond by
sending wu to kill roland's
wu and the board are actually advanced
versions of shield androids called life
model decoys or
lmd's as the shield satellite explodes
near the end of the mini series the wu
lmd decides to stay behind and die like
a human
although the real jimmy wu was thought
to be dead at this time 1993's nickbury
agent of shield number 43 and number 44
revealed that he was one of four agents
put in stasis and brainwashed by hydra
fortunately they are all deep programmed
a few issues later
with the agents of atlas series that
started in 2006 wu led his first comic
in almost 50 years
authority looks good on you jimmy
the first issue of this series reveals
that an elderly wu went rogue and
commanded a team of disenfranchised
shield agents on a raid of the san
francisco branch of the fiendish atlas
foundation
they traveled into a secret room where
the whole team was killed except wu
who was put on life support the only
clues shield can gather link wu's
mission to a short-lived crime-fighting
group from the late 1950s called the
g-men
the agency's sub-director timothy
dum-dum-dugen brings in guerilla man a
member of the g-man for questioning as
he's the only g-man member they can get
a hold of
looking for answers gorilla man secretly
contacts two other g-men members
a robot named m11 and a super-powered
human with genetically engineered
uranium physiology named
marvel boy they helped break wu out of
the hidden shield facility
using his last mental impression of wu
marvel boy restructures him which
restores wu to his 1950s self
at the expense of his memories from the
last 50 years
with his youth regained wu reforms the
agents of atlas to find more leads on
the atlas foundation
derek kanata a wakandan shield agent and
investigator of wu's case travels to
wu's house in order to search for more
clues but the g-men are already there
they initially intend to leave kanata
behind until he says he knows the
location of g-man member venus who can
affect men with her singing
the team travels to africa where they
meet venus and fight the yellow claw
robot
they later travel to antarctica to find
nomura cousin of the atlantean king
namor
who initially refused to join the g-man
and was long thought to be dead
fortunately she's very much alive and
joins the team this time after m11
unfreezes her from her icy coffin wu and
his team subsequently raid several shady
organizations with the name
atlas they finally take a break in fiji
and agents of atlas number four
where they encounter the yellow claw now
known as the golden claw
the team discovers that m11 is a double
agent and after a fight breaks out
between them wu
asks m11 to cut his connection to the
golden claw the final issue of the 2006
agents of atlas series offers a major
reveal for jimmy wu
the team enters the atlas foundation's
secret room in san francisco where they
confront a giant talking dragon named mr
lao
advisor to the atlas foundation's leader
he reveals the organization's origins in
the mongol empire and the golden claw's
real name
even more dramatically it turns out that
wu whose chinese name is wu yen jet was
chosen to be the golden claw successor
shortly after he was born
wu's parents however wanted no
involvement they moved to america and
urged their son to pursue law
enforcement
mr lau believed that if wu could rise up
through the ranks of government his
reputation would grow exponentially
thus when wu was an fbi agent during the
1950s atlas positioned the yellow clause
his nemesis so that the american
government would trust him and his
profile would grow
after learning the truth about who he
really is wu finally takes his place as
the ceo of the atlas foundation
the golden claw then enters mr lyle's
mouth sacrificing himself so that the
rest of the organization will not
question wu's rule with kanata
concealing the team's continued
existence the shield wu and the agents
of atlas enter a strange new future
in issues number 8 through 11 of the
2009 agents of atlas series wu decides
to search for his long-lost loves who
won
mr lao tells wu that after atlas lost
track of him suwon threw herself into
the work of the organization
and was quite good at it too the golden
claw eventually let her run her own
group called the great wall
but after he asked juwan to step down
her loyalists rebelled causing a rift in
the empire
wu travels to china through the dragon's
corridor an alternate dimension
controlled by the atlas foundation to
speak with suwon who now goes by the
moniker jake claw
since wu was violated the atlas great
wall treaty the jade claw attempts to
hold him hostage
but of course wu and his team fight back
the jade claw continues to attack the
atlas foundation's operations until wu's
team once again attacks the great walls
home base
with her force defeated the jade claw
surrenders and wu lets her live to
represent her people
wu leaves the second in command to
oversee the great wall and bring it in
line with the new atlas foundation
in 2013's infinity the hunt number one
it's revealed that wu has co-created a
superhero school with a former super
villain called the pan asian school for
the unusually gifted
this school is located in mumbai and
recruits students from all over asia
this institution is one of many
superhero schools chosen to compete in
the contest of champions
a competition created by hank kim as the
sort of marvel youth olympics
the three students selected to compete
on behalf of the pan-asian school are
the tech genius known as gang the
tendril generating being known as pompom
and a modern incarnation of hindu god
durga
known as sri this initial meaning
between schools is interrupted when
thanos's forces attack earth
in the end the students from each school
work together to defend wakanda
issues number 15 through 18 of 2016's
the totally awesome hulk see woo team up
with a variety of other asian
superheroes
here the head of atlas appears alongside
amadeus cho's hulk
shang chi miss marvel silk and shield
agent jack o at a charity event in
manhattan to raise awareness for asian
american bone marrow donation
they then hang out in korea town and
quickly become friends
unfortunately the group's evening is
interrupted when the extraterrestrial
imperial guard of the planet secnar 7
arrive in new york
although these heroes initially beat the
alien invaders they and the nearby
civilians are transported across the
universe to secnar 7.
the team officially becomes the
protectors in order to keep the
civilians safe from alien threats until
alpha flight arrives to pick them up the
protector is eventually fused with
another superhero team
during 2019's war of the realms event wu
invites the protectors to become the new
agents of atlas
along with a few other heroes while the
team has grown and changed over time
wu's role is a heroic intelligent leader
is remain consistent
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book heroes and
villains are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]